[Musica]
grazie mille grazie soprattutto per
l'invito e oggi parleremo in un mondo
dove la tecnologia la fa da padrone
quali sono qual è l'importanza del
rapporto umano quando uno pensa la
tecnologia sicuramente e vede una
missione spaziale bella associazione di
idee
viene quasi di conseguenza andare nello
spazio è qualcosa che rimarrà per
diverso tempo qualcosa di estremamente
eccitante dal punto di vista personale
ma anche altamente tecnologico pensate
solo che in poco più di 8 minuti e mezzo
bisogna passare da quota zero velocità 0
a oltre 400 km di quota 28mila
chilometri all'ora
quando uno guarda la cabina dello
shuttle come uno la vede qui all'interno
ci sono circa 1300 interruttori diversi
e vi posso assicurare che quando uno
decolla la preparazione è stata talmente
ripetitiva e completa che sa esattamente
a cosa serve qualunque interruttore e in
quale fase però spesso dico che questa
qua non è solo la foto della cabina
dello shuttle ma è la foto di una
piccola azienda perché contrariamente a
quello che accade all'interno della
cabina di un qualsiasi velivolo da
trasporto commerciale
intendo il loro piano normale che noi
prendiamo per andare in vacanza dove il
pilota o il comandante possono
fisicamente allungare una mano e
raggiungere qualunque interruttore che
c'è a bordo su un veicolo spaziale
questo è impossibile sicuramente non lo
era possibile per lo shuttle e quando
melo guardateci schierano certi sistemi
che potrebbero essere comandati solo dal
comandante che sta a sinistra altri che
solo dal pilota che sta a destra e
alcuni solo dall ingegnere di volo che
era seduta al centro
allora ci sono diciamo dei rapporti
delle dinamiche umane che anche in
missioni altamente tecnologiche
diventano predominanti e in particolare
se uno dovesse pensare a tre parole che
descrivono come si crea le relazioni
all'interno di un equipaggio io metterei
competenza fiducia interdipendenza
beh competenza è facile perché ognuno
dei propri compiti e nessun altro è in
grado fisicamente di svolgerli quindi
quando uno parte deve essere
assolutamente preparato per quello che
deve per assolvere i compiti che le sono
stati assegnati
dicevo fiducia perché voglio avere
fiducia in se stesso nelle proprie
capacità fiducia nelle persone che
vengono con te fiducia nella tecnologia
che supporta fiducia nel nella nel team
che ti a destra fiducia nel team che ti
controlla e interdipendenza perché di
sicuro qualunque cosa tu fai a bordo in
qualunque momento ha un effetto sugli
altri allora uno capisce subito che se
pensa per quanto sia bravo di poter
andare nello spazio da solo bello il
momento in cui si ritrova all'interno
della cabina per la prima simulazione si
ricreda subito perché è impossibile
svolgere un compito così complesso da
solo e quindi lavorare in gruppo e forse
alla base del lavoro di un astronauta e
del lavoro di un di un equipaggio di
volo e noi tutti siamo dell'aia degli
esseri umani e ci piace essere messi in
valore per quello che noi sappiamo fare
a bordo
pensate che a bordo un veicolo spaziale
i compiti possono andare da lanciare un
satellite pulire il bagno e vi do un
range ovviamente tutti vorrebbero
lanciare un satellite e nessuno vorrebbe
pulire il bagno
però purtroppo non è così ci sono
compiti come in qualsiasi azienda e
perché questa è un'azienda dicevo prima
qui sono dei compiti diciamo che forse
più appariscenti altri meno
e sta sicuramente nel comandante di
bordo dare la giusta
il giusto bilanciamento tra i membri
dell'equipaggio del dei vari dei vari
compiti e io ho volato diversi anni or
sono ed ero seduto al centro come si
vede in questa foto
quando uno parte per lo spazio
sicuramente sa esattamente che cosa deve
fare quando farlo perché farlo e come
farlo perché gliel'hanno fatto ripetere
talmente tante volte che gli esce dalla
punta dei capelli però come in tutte le
grandi avventure bisogna quando si parte
e bisogna comunque portarsi dietro
alcuni pilastri darsi delle priorità
porta siete le proprie competenze e la
propria entusiasmo la propria
preparazione ma lasciare comunque un po
di mente libera per accettare quello che
ancora non conosciamo perché per chi
vuole la prima volta è ancora un viaggio
verso lo sconosciuto a partire dal fatto
che non uno non sa neanche come si
sentirà da un punto di vista fisico una
volta arrivati in orbita questa una foto
scattata a bordo durante il rilascio di
un satellite e quando si lavora in
orbita c'è una continuità fisica che
difficilmente si sperimenta sulla terra
i corpi si intersecano vi posso
assicurare che quel livello di
sopportazione ad essere estremamente
alto perché la parte che viene a
contatto con te del tuo collega certe
volte non è neanche quella più nobile e
l'altra cosa che noi siamo abituati a
fare quando lavoriamo e lavoriamo
soprattutto se questi schemi nel passato
ci hanno dato una mano e lavorare per
schemi
beh ho voluto portare questa foto perché
quello che vedete si chiama globe box è
un contenitore chiuso all'interno del
quale noi davamo fuoco ad esperimenti di
carta accende le acli accendevamo voi
dite perché è importante è importante
perché quando devi immaginare in un
ambiente chiuso se c'è un incendio o
depressurizzazione è estremamente
rischiosa per l'equipaggio però se io vi
chiedessi come spesso succede purtroppo
durante l'estate qui in italia
in che direzione vanno le fiamme quando
c'è fuoco fuoco in un bosco e quando
tira il vento potuti rispondereste
domanda stupida alla questura della sera
perché le fiamme vanno nella stessa
direzione del vento
poi uno va in orbita da fuoco un pezzo
di carta induce un flusso di corrente
vede che le figlie
se ne vanno in direzione esattamente
contraria a quella del flusso
questo per dire che quando si applicano
degli schemi e noi tendiamo lavorare per
schemi soprattutto quando questi schemi
hanno dato dei risultati nel passato e
non dobbiamo mai dimenticarci delle
condizioni al contorno perché queste
sono determinanti per capire qual è il
risultato che ci potrà dare questo
schema
ovviamente volare nello spazio da un
punto di vista personale una grande
avventura
si rivede il mondo da un'altra
prospettiva non si vede il mondo come
una pallina come certe volte vediamo
perché quello si vede da distanze
prossima la luna che sono 400.000 km
mentre in orbita bassa terrestre si va a
400 chilometri però è già sufficiente
per vedere la superficie della terra
dimensione di continente soprattutto a
vedere questa piccolissima striscia
azzurra che l'atmosfera che mantiene la
vita sulla terra così come noi la
conosciamo è un cambiamento di
prospettiva perché un cambiamento di
colori che la cosa più appariscente noi
siamo abituati a pensare al cielo blu la
terra scura poi uno va in orbita vede
che il cielo è nero e la terra è blu da
qualcosa che colpisce nel più profondo
dell'animo o alcune foto perché non
potevo andarmene senza aver mostrato
alcune foto della terra vista dallo
spazio
modena sarà da qualche parte da in mezzo
questa è torino e alcune foto prese
dallo spazio queste sono delle dune
ripresa al largo e sulla costa della
namibia in nell'africa sud occidentale e
poi per capire il cambiamento di
prospettiva non si capisce e dava anche
da questa foto questa è una foto del
monte everest e sicuramente fa molta
meno impressione vista dall'alto verso
il basso che non dal basso verso l'alto
cambiamento di prospettiva è molto
importante soprattutto nelle relazioni
umane
siamo nella mia esperienza personale ho
avuto a che fare con moltissimi manager
e li potrei dividere in due grandi
categorie ci sono persone che vogliono
raggiungere gli obiettivi lavorando con
delle persone e dei manager che vogliono
lavorare con delle persone per
raggiungere gli obiettivi e la
differenza secondo me tra passione e
pressione ordinare a qualcuno di fare
qualcosa o coinvolgere le persone
in un programma con condiviso dove loro
possono dare il meglio di loro stesse e
il segreto delle relazioni di lavorare
con delle persone è sicuramente alla
base di qualunque progetto che possa
avere un minimo di successo
infatti è proprio la dimensione di
queste relazioni umane che fa la
differenza tra un successo sostenuto e
invece il fallimento l'altra cosa di cui
non poteva non parlare e di come un
astronauta sede la terra dallo spazio
perché è qualcosa che colpisce veramente
nel più profondo del nostro animo non ci
sono argomenti al giorno d'oggi come
inquinamento deforestazione siccità che
sono concetti razionali che noi dobbiamo
metabolizzare per cercare di capire che
cosa si relazionano poi uno ha fortuna
di andare nello spazio e non ci vuole un
rocket santis come dicono gli americani
per capire questo qua il lago ciad in
ciad che una volta era grande così e
adesso si è ridotta al centro siccità
diventa un immagine che è molto più
potente di qualunque parola stessa cosa
per l'inquinamento quello che vedete la
parte ovest della cina
si chiama red basin quella che vedete
non sono nubi di vapore a come sono nubi
di smog
ci sono centinaia di milioni di persone
che bruciano combustibili fossili
il primo commento è va beh questa è la
cina questa è la pianura padana in
determinati periodi dell'anno
e questa è la foresta amazzonica dove
deforestazione assume questo contorno
dove una strada dove gli alberi vengono
tagliati erano pianificazioni al centro
ci sono alcune cose che mi sono portato
dietro dalla dal mio volo spaziale ho
applicato anche in in altre attività
professionali che è soprattutto quello
che qualunque cosa noi facciamo anche
quando lavoriamo con l'alta tecnologia
dobbiamo sempre avere uno spirito aperto
per accettare il nuovo che ci viene
e poi molti domandano come si fa per
cercare di raggiungere l'eccellenza
ognuno ha il proprio meccanismo per me
quello che ha funzionato e qualunque
cosa abbia fatto avere sempre un minimo
di insoddisfazione perché quello che poi
alla fine ti spinge al alla sfida
successiva a dare il più di te stesso
e perché in qualunque organizzazione ha
un valore altamente ha certamente un
grande valore quello dell'eccellenza
individuale per migliorare
l'organizzazione perché gli altri ti
guardano e soprattutto tu che puoi
modificare e migliorare attraverso la
leadership
l'esempio e poi comunque per qualunque
squadra difficile fare squadra se se tu
vuoi volare e come dice questo linus
se vuoi volare circondati di aquile e
non di polli grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]